hi guys this is Luca from local umbrella
comm and today I have an announcement to
make I've been invited to explore lingua
2019 as a language ambassador as a
polyglot and as an influencer explain
what 2019 is the huge is the biggest
event actually organized in terms of
language learning every single year in
Germany and it is a fantastic event if
you are a language enthusiast if you're
having your own business you want to
make connections there's all sorts of
businesses and schools and language
organizations and materials you name it
if you like languages you should
definitely come to this language fair as
I said this language fair is going to
take place on the 22nd and on the 23rd
of November Friday and Saturday on
Friday I'm going to host an event with
two other Italian youtubers stefanos we
go who's a good friend of mine and
Lucrezia who's got a very popular
channel for those who are learning
Italian it you can come greet and meet
and we're going to chat about learning
Italian learning other languages in
Italian and other languages you name it
it's a very cool and unique event and on
Saturday the following day we have in
the afternoon early afternoon a polyglot
talk with other very cool youtubers and
polyglots stefan zweig is still going to
be there and also Lena and ELISA police'
and then I have my own presentation
about the ten golden rules to learn any
language so apart from my presentation
and the events that are going to happen
with the other polyglots it's overall an
amazing experience you should come and
we're going to have a fun and a
fantastic time see you very soon in
Berlin oh and one more thing if I have
put all the information about how to get
a free ticket all the events etc in the
description box so please click below
and you will see all the information you
need again see you soon in Berlin bye